a sion de la candidature d eczéma ou au
moment où se tient l'ultime débat télé
ce soir des républicains dernier sprint
pour les cinq prétendants à
l'investiture présidentielle et à quatre
jours de la désignation du candidat
officiel
place désormais au décryptage
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec eric revel éditorialiste politique
merci eric revel d'être avec nous qui va
apparaître dans quelques instants et
voilà on est content de vous revoir
merci à vous d'être là sur ce plateau
alexis poulain bonsoir alexis poulain
éditorialistes rc france avec nous
également pour représenter et voilà ans
qui rentre direct et qui nous rejoint
jérémy michel bon ami avocat membre des
amis d'eric zemmour bonsoir jérémy
michel merci d'être avec nous alors plus
de dix minutes de vidéo pour
officialiser sa candidature la fin d'un
faux suspense votre réaction alexis on
imagine que vous étiez devant votre
écran total a alors non je n'étais pas
obligé de regarder un peu faim en
accéléré ben on attendait cette
déclaration il fallait qu'elle arrive
alors on savait que ça allait arriver
d'ici le 30 novembre c'est fait l'idée
c'est de beugin peu le congrès des
républicains c'est fait c'est aussi une
forme particulière à une vidéo sur
youtube une plate forme d'un gaza avec
des des extraits vidéo dont il n'a pas
les droits donc déjà là ça pose une
question pourquoi eric zemmour n'est pas
entouré du juriste qui lui ont dit
attention ne peut pas prendre ces vous
de vidéos on n'a pas le droit alors si
c'est pour faire du buzz c'est raté et
puis cette mise en scène où on voit bien
qu'ils essayent de faire écho à la vidéo
bien sûr l'appel du 18 juin du général
de gaulle avec le micro vintage le
discours dans les mains c'est formidable
j'ai l'impression que c'est le candidat
de la nostalgie qui arrivent pour dire
la france c'était quand même mieux avant
voilà eric revel vous attendiez ce type
de vidéos alors c'est vrai que
voilà que c'était peut-être un peu
surprenant vous l'avait qualifié
commando punis
écoutez d'abord
sur sur la forme bon toutou rappelle
évidemment le général de gaulle certains
lui ont reproché de ne pas regarder les
français dans les yeux mais de gaulle
quand ils disent on l'appel du 18 juin
il est à la radio donc par définition il
n'y a pas de caméra donc il son discours
dont la mise en scène est parfaite alors
qu'ils s'adressent être catégories de
français ceux qui estiment que la france
c'était mieux avant commune alexis mais
très curieusement c'est sur youtube et
qu'ils postent sa vidéo pour déclarer sa
candidature à la présidentielle et là il
ya un petit bug d'un petit antagonismes
parce que les gens auxquels ils
s'adressent ils sont plutôt les gens
nostalgiques et d'un certain âge je
pense même si des jeunes ont rejoint ces
gens là par définition ils sont pas sur
youtube donc là il ya un petit truc qui
me semble un peu bizarre et si vous
regardez bien la vidéo vous apercevrez
que tout le monde en prend pour son
grade bien sûr le président macron bien
sûr
les candidats de des républicains il ya
une seule personne qui naquit n'est pas
citée donc il n'est pas si blessé marine
le pen dans ce dans cette vidéo donc ça
c'est aussi très intéressant maintenant
certains ont trouvé cette vidéo rend
certains ont dit c'est le micro du
général de gaulle mais derrière c'est la
bibliothèque du maréchal pétain bon tout
le monde s'il donnait
il ya été de sa petite phrase de
commentaire il ya cette septième
symphonie deuxième mouvement de la paix
domaine en arrière fond musical qui
rajoute à la gravité du du moment le
clip est assez bien foutu j'ai trouvé
alterné des images d'une france passé et
d'une france actuelle maintenant
je ne suis pas certain que ça parlera à
tous les français et à tous le lectorat
qu'eric zemmour vous
touchés oui j'ai discuté avec des amis
cet après midi qu'il a expliqué qu'en
fait moi j'appartenais une génération
qui ne comprenaient pas ou qui ne
comprenaient plus l'évolution du monde
savait c'était mieux avant quand vous
dites ça vous appartenez à une
génération ou qualifie parfois denses
entre guillemets part de déboires on
qualifie de vieux cons voyez donc est ce
que il exerce adresse à toute la france
possibles y compris celle qui est en
train d'évoluer grâce au digital et qui
est un peu universaliste et
multiculturelle ou bien est ce qu il
cible une clientèle électorale plus
restreinte mais qui va constituer un
socle en même temps eric zemmour lance
son parti politique un beaucoup de gens
ont été contactés dès ce matin pour pour
adhérer pour rejoindre ce mouvement
d'eric zemmour donc la machine est en
marche maintenant une campagne c'est
extrêmement l'eau une campagne ça coûte
extrêmement cher
on est surtout si on est pas certain qu
eric zemmour aura la capacité en fait de
développer tout ce qu'il veut dire qu'on
en parle et rit on va peut-être
pardonnez moi elle éprouvait alors on va
vous redonner évidemment la parole non
va donner aussi la parole quand même aux
seuls représentants officiels d'eric
zemmour sur ce plateau jérémy mais chez
michel quand on entend dire voilà que
revient la l'instant et j'ai beaucoup de
critiques dans la journée que il s'est
coupé peut-être peut-être une partie de
son électorat notamment les jeunes parce
que c'est vrai que ce clip semblait
s'arrêtait plus ou moins aux années
soixante dix le concorde les films de
claude sautet bref une france un peu
passéiste donc on regrette vous l'avez
vous êtes jeune vous même est ce que
vous l'avez ressenti comme ça chez les
amis d'eric zemmour est ce que vous êtes
plutôt satisfait de ce montage vidéo
écoutez déjà merci beaucoup de me
recevoir ce soir évidemment que nous
sommes satisfaits on peut être jeune et
en même temps se dire que ce qui a été
la france eh bien ça ne l'est plus et
que qu'il faut faire ce constat et s'est
déporté vers l'avenir moi je vais vous
dire quand j'ai vu ce clip vidéo que
j'ai trouvé extrêmement bon vraiment
excellent autant sur la forme d'ailleurs
que sur le fond sur la forme d'ailleurs
ne vous inquiétez pas
nous avons les droits sur les images et
on a très bon juriste dans l'équipe eh
bien écoutez moi j'ai été émue j'ai été
ému tout simplement parce que derrière
cette ce discours d'eric zemmour il y a
une énergie il ya une force et un élan
il ya un espoir qui est donné donc moi
j'entends en effet certaines critiques
visent à dire qu'il serait pas si c'est
et c mais si on ne connaît pas son
histoire si on ne sait pas qui nous
sommes d'où nous venons nous ne serons
pas où nous devons aller et dans cette
vidéo vous verrez et vous avez dû le
constater il parle en effet de la france
mais il parle aussi de son avenir et ils
parlent ils ne parlent pas une clientèle
j'entends d'une mode clientèle non il
parle aux français en effet par le
français parle de la france aux français
comme le général de gaulle en son temps
il est vrai 12,7 cette comparaison est
jeu j'aimerais noter quand même que
cette vidéo on dit les personnes âgées
etc sont pas sur youtube c'est pas vrai
faudra regarder les statistiques on est
à plus d'un million de vues on est à
plus d'un million de vues pour une vidéo
qui est quand même sortie à midi
aujourd'hui on s'taille toutes les
chaînes infos ont diffusé cette cette
vidéo et on peut d'ailleurs s'en
interrogé alexis poule a on va voir
donner une âme à la parole c'est vrai
que c'est une sacrée tribune
eric zemmour il y avait des éditions
spéciales we shall info tout alors me
dit c'est toute la l'allèle la
dichotomie des chaînes info elles sont
perdues entre eux est ce qu on fait trop
de publicité exil ou pas ces temps-ci ce
soir je suis re le fait mais on doit le
faire puisque on commente la politique
française et il fait partie maintenant
de la politique française puisqu'il est
candidat officiellement candidat les
choses vont changer à la fois avec les
règles du cssa là bien sûr le la
campagne et son financement
là ce soir à l'exo moore est aussi au jt
de 20h nationale il ya huit camions de
gendarmes pour sécuriser sa venue c'est
un barnum eric zemmour c'est un cirque
politico médiatique comme on en n'avait
plus fait depuis mené le maquereau donc
on va retrouver à peu près les mêmes
choses des coups de buzz dès que eric
zemmour dit quelque chose toute la
presse va arriver alors c'est le début
de la campagne ça risque de s'essouffler
peut-être au bout d'un certain temps
mais on voit bien que là il a des
millions d'équivalent en termes de pub
c'est par les chaînes d'info d'abord il
était évidemment mis sur les fonts
baptismaux par ses news la chaîne de
vincent bolloré qui lui a fait un pont
d'or pour qu'ils puissent commencer à
faire campagne sans faire campagne aux
réalités mais à rentrer dans le foyer
des français tous les soirs avec son
émission face à l'info aujourd'hui le
voilà il capitalise sur cette célébrité
médiatique alors on va entendre une ou
deux réactions politiques c'est vrai
qu'elles sont toutes négatives vous
l'avez constaté cet après midi à l'est
les opposants eric zemmour ne sont pas
allés de main morte on va écouter
olivier faur suivie de celle de damien
abad le socialiste suivi donc du
républicain
le micro de de gaulle mais le discours
de pétain la bibliothèque de pompidou
mais les lettres de renaud camus la
musique de beethoven mais les fausses
notes d'un passé fantasmé par un présent
caricaturer la france ne mérite pas
cette sinistre mise en scène
prétendre faire la france avec une
fraction c'est une erreur grave et
prétendre représenter la france au nom
d'une fraction est une erreur
impardonnable
le futur président doit réconcilier les
français et non chercher à les fractures
et eric revel ça c'est une critique qui
est revenu souvent cette histoire de
deux fractures de division est ce que
c'est quelque chose qui peut notamment
faire fuir l'électorat de droite
traditionnels notamment celle qui a voté
pour françois fillon en 2012 et qui
était certainement peut-être tenté pour
certains par celle d'eric zemmour
écoutez dans la fonction de président de
la république sait que c'est qu'au
substantielle quand vous êtes élu
président de la république vous êtes le
président de tous les français n'est ce
pas donc ça veut dire que même ceux qui
n'ont pas voté pour eux vous êtes obligé
de rassembler d'avoir à ton rassembleur
donc
la candidature d'eric zemmour avons à
mon sens
rentrer dans ce mur là parce que en
réalité là dans le positionnement qui
est le sien et il ne rassemble pas alors
je voudrais quand même rajouter quelque
chose parce que j'entendais ce jeune
représentant de d'eric zemmour au
premier sens du terme
il ya quelque chose d'émouvant je suis
d'accord dans ce clip il ya quelque
chose d'émouvant c'est à dire que on a
des images d'un passé je suis désolé
pour olivier faure qui est pas fantasmer
le passé peut pas être lente aspect
puisqu'il a existé donc il peut pas être
fantasmes et c'est pas un fantasme
c'était une réalité et ce passé là alors
peut-être que la maladresse ou ou
l'exagération propre provocatrice c'est
c'est de mettre que des images
absolument superbe du passé de la france
et que des images absolument horrible de
la france d'aujourd'hui dans les deux
cas dans le passé quand même il ya eu
les images qui était pas tout reluisante
1 vous savez il ya eu aussi mai 68 il ya
eu aussi des affrontements coloniaux ici
ou ailleurs dans le passé français et
puis aujourd'hui bien sûr qu'à tous les
problèmes que et l'eczéma mission la
table et qui de toute façon laisseront
des traces à droite parce qu'il aura une
certaine manière d'état bozizé la façon
fonctionner de la droite mais le présent
actuel de la france c'est pas seulement
cela il ya aussi plein d'autres choses
qui sont quand même assez jolie et est
assez réussie alors en termes de
communication on verra comment les
choses vont se passer c'est vrai que la
fenêtre de tir est extrêmement un film
parce qu'il ya le congrès des
républicains mais il y avait aussi
aujourd'hui l'entrée au panthéon de
joséphine baker jeudi bakker parce que
la grande chanteuse voulait qu'on
prononce son nom la française bakker et
non pas baker donc ça c'est une réponse
en fait subliminal et indirects au clip
un peu passéistes d'eric zemmour avec
l'entrée de la première femme noire même
si c'est pas son corps parce qu'on sait
que c'est la terre qui rentrait au
panthéon mais en terme de symbole et de
communication on veut aussi ce qu'a
voulu signifier le présent la république
emmanuel macron c'est à dire que voilà
une femme qui a été résistante qui était
noir et d'une certaine manière et en
même temps emmanuel macron renvoie dos à
dos ce clip de manière presque
subliminale mais il renvoie aussi d'une
autre manière même temps ça c'est macro
il renvoie en même temps la montée
incessante de la consult culture et la
remise en cause par le voc isme qui lui
vient des états unis de l'histoire
nationale et du roman national voilà je
voulais rajouter ça parce que il ya
quelque chose d'émouvant moi je pense
que si mes grands parents ou mon père
avait vu ce clip nonobstant ce qu'il
peut penser politiquement des uns et des
autres il ya quelque chose de touchant
parce que on voit des images d'une
france qui quand même a disparu sous nos
yeux alors jérémy un michel c'est vrai
que l'on voit cette france là mais on
voit comme l'a souligné évidemment eric
revel aussi ces images apocalyptiques
c'est d'ailleurs le mot employé par le
maire de béziers robert ménard qui a
déploré un message justement trop
apocalyptique c'est vrai que ça peut
peut-être interpellé ces images de
violences extrêmes on a le sentiment
quand on sort de chez nous c'est une
véritable guerre civile or ce n'est
quand même pas le cas tout est aussi
noir ne déplorait pas justement que ce
message soit peut-être un peu trop
voyant dans ce clip des ligues zemmour
alors écoutez c'était pas eric zemmour
qui est dont vous parlé d' apocalypse et
j'en attends robert ménard c'est vous le
citez en effet mais d'autres ont fait
cette comparaison n'est ce pas mais ce
sont des images de la france
d'aujourd'hui ça personne ne dit le
contraire n'est ce pas attendez ça ce
sont des images de la france
d'aujourd'hui eric zemmour pose un
diagnostic dans la première partie de
cette vidéo et ce diagnostic alors
évidemment qu'il ya des choses qui vont
très bien dans notre pays mais il faut
aussi voir les réalités voir ce qui pose
problème les problèmes d'intégration les
problèmes de sécurité les solutions
régaliennes qu'il faut mettre face à
cela je sais que ce que je vais vous
dire si vous voulez c'est que moi en
tant que que jeune j'ai été émue de
cette vidéo je pense qu'on n'a pas
besoin d'avoir 70 ans pour être ému en
voyant ce que la france a été et donc ce
qu'elle peut être est ce qu'elle peut
redevenir au contraire je pense que
l'histoire peut émouvoir et doit et vous
voir les jeunes générations et c'est à
ça que ça sert l'histoire l'histoire ça
sert pas être postale jcsa sert
justement à donner un espoir aux jeunes
générations alors rappelé que nous avons
été nous devons conserver et ce que nous
devons porter vers l'avenir donc j'y
vois pas du tout une vision
apocalyptique au contraire j'y vois des
diagnostics eric zemmour a fait pendant
15 ans et qui se réalise sous nos yeux
et en tant que jeune je préfère
quelqu'un qui a le courage de parler de
la radicalité du réel car c'est le réel
qui est radicale c'est pas le discours
d'eric zemmour c'est le réel et qui a le
courage de le dire de le montrer et de
proposer des solutions et d'ailleurs
tout le monde lui courent après et c'est
pas pour rien que entre guillemets on
parle de buzz etc c'est tout simplement
parce qu'il interpelle les gens et qu'il
interpelle aussi les jeunes et c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de jeunes sur
youtube un million de vues il ya aucun
homme politique qui fait ça aujourd'hui
et j'aimerais juste rajouter une
dernière chose une anecdote qui est kim
hakima qui m'a beaucoup fait rigoler on
parle beaucoup de polémiste d'extrême
droite or déjà je le mets sur la table
j'ai pas envie qu'on dise qu'avec des
mois d'extrême droite c'est pas du tout
le cas dans la plupart de ses
propositions sur le régalien fillon
avait pu faire des propositions du même
ordre donc c'est une personne de droite
en effet mais qui parle à toute la
droite assez droite hors les murs qui a
été longtemps orpheline à tel point
qu'ils aient une vidéo sur youtube si
vous allez sur la chaîne des
républicains la vidéo qui est le plus vu
sur la chaîne des républicains c'est une
invitation de laurent wauquiez eric
zemmour hockey qui lui dit tu es ici
chez toi bon ça c'était en janvier 2019
c'est la vidéo la plus vue puisqu'on
parlait de youtube donc ça montre bien
qu'il ya une attente dans ce qu'on
pourrait appeler le peuple de droite
mais plus largement le peuple français
qui quelque part s'est droitisée parce
que la réalité de droite tout simplement
et moi derrière ceux qui voient là j'ai
été ému c'est vrai que je suis un jeune
trentenaire mais pour autant je suis
attaché à l'histoire de la france à son
à son héritage que j'aimerais recevoir
et pouvoir perpétuer voilà alexis boulin
on voit un jeune nuls un ami de zemmour
pour autant est ce qu'il y a eu un début
de solution c'est vrai que eric zemmour
dans ce message dont un diagnostic
et c'est vrai que c'est un diagnostic
connu un qui l'a fait de livre en livre
depuis une quinzaine d'années une
vingtaine d'années donc rien de nouveau
je pense qu'il faut attendre de voir qui
sera avec lui sur la scène lors de son
meeting son premier meeting de campagne
et puis ensuite le programme parce qu'on
voit bien que depuis l'élection des
modèles mâcon le programme est devenu un
projet puis finalement ce n'est plus le
centre de la campagne est également chez
les républicains qui font des débats et
un débat ce soir encore c'est les idées
d'eric zemmour enfin celles qui sont
partagés sur le constat qui sont au
centre des discussions depuis des
semaines déjà sur l'immigration sur
l'intégration sur la sécurité etc donc
cdc des moments partagés après la
réalité je pense pas qu'elle est de
droite ou de gauche elles existent on la
voit avec des yeux de droite ou des yeux
de gauche où on a les deux et on peut
faire quelque chose mais la question
posée le constat posé par exemple je
trouve qu'il est partagé qu'il peut être
rassembleur la preuve un million de vues
ce n'est pas rien et je trouve les les
oppositions extrêmement désemparé
désarmés c'est à dire ça ne sert à rien
de toujours critiquer eric zemmour par
des quolibets par des des blagues part
du détournement derrière il ya des idées
qui sont des idées importantes qui font
partie du débat alors il ya eu de la
radicalité je pense que zemmour candidat
va devoir mettre un peu d'eau dans son
vin et commencer à être moins radical
que le polémiste qu'on a vu sur les
plateaux de télé ou dans ses livres
parce que c'est là que ça risque d'être
compliqué le jeu politique est assez
hypocrite et on voit bien que il ya des
codes qui sont pas forcément les mêmes
alors peut-être que son but c'est de
dynamiter les codes d'essayer de faire
ça est-ce que ça peut marcher je ne sais
pas on voit bien que pour le moment ça
plaît en termes d'audience en tout cas
on a posé la question aux
téléspectateurs qui ont réagi
effectivement ces nombreux aujourd'hui
sur notre compte et les g on a pu en
sélectionné quelques-uns seymour n'a pas
de programme c'est un polémiste écrivain
parrain politique et encore moins un
économiste ça c'est pour mail qu'ils
sébastien qui dit non mais je ne voyais
je ne croyais pas à macron quand il a
déclaré sa candidature je vais donc que
me gardé de tout pronostic à la question
c'était croyez-vous en exe mort et puis
oui complètement pour déguerpir
notamment la macro ni c'est ce que nous
dit patrick
évidemment de plus en plus fort et ce
n'est que le début nous dit pascal
également eric revel ce n'est que le
début vous pensez parce que maintenant
il va falloir se positionner évidemment
face entre marine le pen et face aux
républicains ça va aller de plus en plus
fort où il va falloir au contraire
peut-être adoucir l'image de la
stratégie des prochains mois et des
prochaines semaines va être important
pour réaliser mourant pertes dans les
sondages
alors deux choses si vous permettez la
première je relis bien un petit peu en
développant ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est à dire que quoi qu'il
arrive pour eric zemmour avec cette
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
il y aura un avant et un après je pense
quand vous regardez justement les débats
des républicains que vous voyez bien que
la radicalisation sur des thèmes que la
droite dite républicaine ne portait pas
avant maintenant il ya plus de tabou
c'est à dire que la droite républicaine
porte sur la table des thèmes que le rpr
des années 90 porter ou que le racing
nationale portée avant donc il y aura un
avant et un après eric zemmour quelle
que soit la direction va prendre sa
candidature parce que d'une certaine
manière il aura permis me semble-t-il à
la droite de passer de l'état de
chenilles à celle du papillon certains
vont trouver papier moche d'autres
préféreront se souvenir de la chimie
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que il
aura bêta brisé en certains d'une
certaine manière maintenant sur la suite
de la campagne
quand vous regardez ce qui préoccupe les
français bien sûr la montée des
violences la question de la sécurité la
question de de l'immigration même si
dans son clip dis quand même il adoucit
un peu il dit l'immigration n'est pas
responsable de tout mais en rajoute sur
nos problèmes voyez vous avez vu le
distinguo dit pas c'est l'immigration
que l'immigration est encore les
migrations dans le clip il dit
l'immigration nous facilite pas le
boulot mais n'est pas responsable de
tout déjà il met une petite goutte d'eau
dans son vin puis deuxième chose était
une quinte reste français aujourd'hui
c'est le pouvoir d'achat ce sont les
prestations sociales ce sont quand même
les réformes économiques l avenir de
leurs enfants la question que je pose
toute bête qui pas que les autres en
plus de crédibilité mais est ce qu eric
zemmour aura suffisamment de force
d'idées de crédibilité pour porter un
discours économique et social loin de
ses bases un peu à la jacques bainville
cet historien du roman national loin de
l'historien et du polémiste ça c'est une
question parce qu'à un moment donné
falloir qu'ils se découvrent qu'ils
découvrent son programme les français
jugeront t'il qu'il a des solutions
crédibles pour parler d'économie ou de
social ça me semble t'il ce sera un vrai
temps une vraie provocation jérémy
michel ça c'est vrai et c'est d'ailleurs
c'est la remarque de nos téléspectateurs
tout à l'heure ça pèche sur l'économie
c'est vrai qu'on entend peu parler
règlement d'économie il a parlé de la
réindustrialisation de la france mais
sauf erreur de ma part c'est à peu près
tout c'est vrai qu'il est peut-être
léger sur ce sujet vous diriez
écouter non pas du tout vous pouvez
regarder le débat qu'il a eue face à
alain minc est également le débat qu'il
a eue face à denis olivennes il a été
très très très solide posé sur ses bases
sur les sujets économiques maîtrise très
très bien depuis des années moi ce que
j'aimerais vous dire aussi c'est qu'à
titre personnel au sein des amis d'eric
zemmour moi et d'autres nous
réfléchissons à des éléments
programmatiques avec des jeunes
professionnels de jeunes experts mais
aussi des plus expérimentés et et donc
il ya un vrai une vraie émulation si
vous voulez dans notre camp sur ce que
nous pouvons ce que nous voulons faire
pour la france mais ça viendra j'imagine
bientôt donc donc il ya un travail qui a
été fait si vous voulez collectivement
au sein de l'association des amis d'eric
zemmour mais il ya aussi un travail qui
était fait un parent par eric zemmour il
a essaimé tout un ensemble de
propositions il y eu cette proposition
sur les bas salaires de baisse ou de
suppression pardon de la csg crds pour
justement offert un treizième au
français il ya eu cette proposition ce
discours à bordeaux devant les
entrepreneurs sur la création d'une
autorité pour simplifier la vie
économique mais aussi pour
réindustrialiser la france il ya tout un
ensemble de propositions je crois que
valeurs actuelles avaient en avait
dénombré 70 donc c'est pas mal donc il
avance sur ces sujets il avance sur tous
les sujets sur l'immigration ce qu'il a
dit ce n'est pas nouveau il a toujours
dit ce que c'est mais sur l'économie on
a peut-être plus de mal à voir un
programme même vraiment lisible ou est
ce qu'ils se classent c'est vrai quand
il dit avec un appartement de 150 m² à
paris on n'est pas riche ça veut dire
quoi qu on se coupe peut-être d'une
partie d'un électorat populaire dans
l'est ça a choqué dans l'est parce que
sachant qu est alors si vous avez acheté
votre appartement de 150 m² en 1950 par
exemple 1970 et que vos revenus n'ont
pas évolué depuis
écoutez
vous serez bien à la peine de payer
l'imposition sur ce sur ce bien
immobilier il faut voir les choses de
façon totalement dynamique je crois que
dans les années 2000 le prix du mètre
carré ça devait être aux alentours de
2000 euros à paris aujourd'hui dans
certains quartiers on à 18000 euros donc
voilà ce qui voulait dire par là c'est
tout simplement que bon voila quand on
acquiert un bien à un moment et que les
revenus évolue pas eh bien ce moment là
on peut se retrouver bien à la peine
donc voilà maintenant très simplement
sur l'économie moi ce que je comprends
de ses prises de positions qu'elle soit
dans les médias ou dans ses livres c'est
quelqu'un qui veut redonner de la
liberté aux français qui veut leur
permettre d'entreprendre mais aussi de
travailler de vivre de leur travail tout
simplement
dans un discours qui à mon sens
s'adressent tout particulièrement mais
pas que à la france des entrepreneurs
mais aussi à la france d'aider gilet
jaune qui il faut le rappeler était des
français sont des français qui
travaillent mais qui ne peuvent pas
vivre de leur travail et qui ont été
matraqués et flash ball ise excusez-moi
de 2,2 ce néologisme par le camp le camp
au pouvoir et je voulais en venir à ça
est ce qui est important pour moi parce
que tout à l'heure
on disait voilà le président doit
rassembler mais on rassemble pas autour
du vide on rassemble autour d'un projet
d'un cap et eric zemmour est quasiment
le seul dans cette dans cette campagne
maintenant à fixer un cap pour la france
a fixé un projet qui soit
civilisationnel économique et il ya des
propositions dans dans sa vidéo alors
que je suis désolé mais le camp au
pouvoir c'est quand même un camp qui
gouvernent par la violence on l'a vu
avec les gilet jaune moi j'ai vu des
filles de 21 ans éborgné cema rien quand
même à 21 ans d'être éborgné on parle de
violence faite aux femmes ben voilà une
sas est un exemple mais c'est aussi le
camp de la diabolisation qui ne joue que
là dessus c'est à dire on va diaboliser
l'adversaire on va le traiter de ceci et
de racistes d'extrême droite et cetera
et ce n'est que comme ça que le camp au
pouvoir espère se maintenir voyez bien
que sur le fond des propositions ils ne
répondent jamais ils ne répondent jamais
et et et leurs objectifs il est clair
c'est d'un visibiliser les propositions
de oxymore qui sont pléthore et je pense
qu'il y en aura d'autres dans les mois
les mois à venir mais y en a déjà plus
de soixante dix qui ont été données on
arrive à la fin d'un autre débat juste
coup d'oeil sur un dernier sondage un
sondage qui date d'aujourd'hui enquête
pour l'institut harris interactive pour
challenge c'était évidemment avant ce
message aux candidatures macron qui à
23% marine le pen un deuxième tour 19%
et bertrand 14 eric zemmour 1 qui qui
perd 3 à 4 points par rapport à la
semaine dernière qui a 13 % alexis
poulain vous pariez sur une remontée
après ce message de candidature écoutez
c'est pour un candidat tout 900 équipes
sans programme 13 % c'est énorme même si
il avait déjà été gonflé par les autres
sondages ce qu'on peut voir dans ce
sondage c'est par contre le poids du ce
qu'on appelle le camp national marine le
pen eric zemmour ensemble c'est bien
devant emmanuel macron et ce camp
national s'ils s'unissent il fait
quelque chose si certains cadres de l
air font sécession suite au vote pour un
candidat ça peut totalement changé la
donne de l'élection de 2022 avec
effectivement un projet de société d'un
côté les mondialistes la start up nation
les européistes ont continué de l'autre
côté qu'est ce que le souverainisme
qu'est ce qu'on veut faire un choc
libéral à la thatcher d'une certaine
façon et là on aurait un débat de fond
de fond avec des candidats classiques
comme le ps ait l'air ou qui auraient du
mal à exister et puis de l'autre côté
jean luc mélenchon qui est recouvert
faire un bloc de gauche sur la aussi des
propositions plus radicale ce que je
vois dans cette candidature c'est le
retour du politique les critiques
confère exe moore de dire il est pas
économiste il est pas de techno il n'a
pas fait l'ena il a raté l'ena tant
mieux tant mieux ça va enfin faire un
débat politique on va sortir de ce cadre
technocratique de finalement deux pas de
là bien pensants semé de la pensée
unique et c'est parce que vous allez
vous retrouver avec votre tête dans le
prochain message
mais dame chance à eric effet
d'excellents voilà valérie trierweiler
d'ailleurs ce soir demande est retiré du
tibet existants mais voilà je pense que
c'est ce que les français attendent un
débat de haut vol d'idée merci en tout
cas à tous les trois eric un revers
alexis poulin et vous évidemment jérémy
michel merci d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france ce soir et hazard
venant du cac